[Applause]
a city under siege as russian forces
intensified their attacks
what's left of neighborhoods in mariopol
are shattered homes and buildings
across the port city scattered bodies
lay out on the street
scenes of the worst war can do
cars now line the streets as people try
to flee
checkpoints make sure only civilians
leave
central
i got out of the city's central district
with bombings and destruction we lost
our house so now we're leaving with our
children we're still in shock and
fearful
russian forces charged into the port
city a place where weeks of shelling had
kept about 400 000 people hostage
local authorities say moscow's attacks
have cut electricity supplies heating
and water russia denies its targeting
civilians
yeah
he freed us from education but
airstrikes have hit civilian
infrastructure like the city school and
recently a theater where people were
taking refuge from bombings
amid those ravaged neighborhoods
survivors say life will never be the
same
a makeshift kitchen is all that's left
of this woman's home and some no longer
have the energy or will to leave
why leave the city now after what we've
been through we've had difficult days
with bombings hunger and cold weather as
you can see our neighborhood is
destroyed
as old lives are left behind some have
found shelter in local schools
with another humanitarian crisis
unfolding
katya lopez
al jazeera